[Music]
lays them in just a couple of weeks for
the second year in a row we are taking
our show down to San Diego for comic-con
[Applause]
anyway what the hell was that will be
would be airing a week of shows live
from the Spreckels theater in San Diego
it's all happening Wednesday July 20th
through Sunday July 24th we've got a ton
of amazing things planned including
interviews with the entire cast Silicon
Valley and the cast from the upcoming
movie Suicide Squad you don't want to
miss those shows reveal like totally
jazzed about Comic Con I'm really
looking get really excited I didn't any
I don't think you were into superheroes
and comics and stuff like oh me I love
superheroes that's where cuz I've never
heard you mention it I've never heard
you once mentioned superheroes or comic
book I'm very into them I'm very
knowledgeable I mean I know all the
heroes and stuff oh you know it all yeah
you could just try me if you want
alright
okay how about I show you a picture of a
superhero you tell me their name oh
absolutely
all right you know all right let's put
this one by one right now
okay that's Batman okay that's the Green
Arrow got it the purple arrow all right
hoverboard mcdu yes Oh chilly shoulders
will very good the human test very nice
Ben Affleck yes captain sticky fingers
nice Gil Fischer wins DDS as a dentist
the Trump supporter
[Applause]
for more details about our week at
comic-con go to team koco.com slash
comic-con toning the comic-con
good Sunday July 24
you